we're going to count down our top five
movies of the year we're not going to
put them in any particular order also I
have five you have five but some of ours
overlap so these are our favorite or top
ones that doesn't mean these movies are
better than world or otherwise there's
other movies on my list that like you
know I'm like oh maybe that should be
there Tom then maybe you can include a
few more yeah yeah so let's start off
with this world food this movie is 12
years a slave this is in your top five
it did not make my top five but it's in
my top 10 so so what do you want to say
Bubba Louie Toby just lay the first of
all it's a rough movie it is difficult
to watch yeah this is the first I want
to say hard at real attempt it
portraying just how violent and how
rough you know slavery no Antebellum
slavery was here in America amistad with
Steven Spielberg its kind of light I
mean for what it was I thought our roots
your family channel good series but you
know it's the family channel this really
goes hard it's goes like kind of
Schindler's List hard if I can compare
to that I compared maybe the schindlers
list of Antebellum slavery great
performances first of all you tell
Ejiofor Michael Fassbender benedict
cumberbatch paul Guillen Brad Pitt this
goes on and on and on I can't pronounce
this young actress who's nominated for a
golden globe who plays I guess I would
call her the leading lady and then is
excellent as well newcomer a great role
for her just an all-around great
performance when those movies I think
you said this afternoon we too is it you
see it once you're good hard to watch it
difficult yeah great performances I I
think it's the reason why yeah I think
it didn't make it into my top five but
only in my top ten is because of that
like I don't know how much I you know I
can see this again and there's actually
several movies like this as well that
aren't in my top we saw Joff buyers club
dallas buyers club and fruitvale station
are like two movies that are similar in
that way where they're they're very
difficult to watch and so I don't know
how you know how much I'm gonna watch
the movies again even though there are
all excellent movies right I just
appreciate director Steve McQueen taking
you know Fassbender again for the third
time hunger
shame and now now this and just really
just tackling these tough issues that I
think a lot of you know you had
Tarantino head Django Unchained but
that's that's got some comedy you can
laugh a little bit through that this you
don't really laughs there's no laughter
no no its you throughout its heavy um so
I I really enjoyed it's definitely one
of my top five all right cool and so the
next movie this is in my top five mud
with Matthew McConaughey I think Matthew
McConaughey has is having this year yeah
he's having a still a year because he
has to oscar-worthy nominated lead roles
one in mud one in dallas buyers club and
in a movie i'll be talking about later
wolf of Wall Street he's not a
supporting actor he's only in the movie
maybe like 10 15 minutes mm-hmm but it's
a scene-stealing 10 to 15 minutes it's
good you'll remember so like he's having
a banner year yeah this movie I really
liked it a lot it's it's it's a movie
it's about love but it's about like
these different kind of aspects and
situations and love like young love and
the infatuation then you have like a
love falling apart like the main
characters parents and then you had the
mathematic ohne Hayes character and
reese witherspoon and that was like the
one that they were trying to bring
together so that you know there's a
great relationship between between the
young kids and Matthew McConaughey's
character so yeah it's definitely in my
top five how about you i enjoyed it um
is in your top ten and all you know no i
don't wanna be my top ten but it was
really good i appreciated i appreciated
matthew mcconaughey's performance dallas
buyers club would definitely in my top
ten this would be in my top ten i
actually liked seeing Reese i came away
like you know she's always doing that
kind of chick flicks perdia movies you
know Sweet Home Alabama which is a
little rough little more characters not
that likable no way in this and I like
that like that she wasn't the
sweethearts and everybody adores I like
that but Matthew McConaughey is
definitely his year he's just an honest
I'd nota Michael Shannon is also honest
as arrows odd you know agent Van Alden
right boardwalk he's in it as well and
he gives it does a good job as well just
not a huge huge part right right
alright so the next movie we got on the
list this is your on your top eyes neill
blomkamp is back with us follow up from
district nine supposed to be the
director of halo maybe sometimes the
future of probably never happen that's
okay uh I I love this movie because I
liked it bum camp tackles tough issues
you know district nine you had the whole
kind of parallel to the apartheid in
South Africa take place in Johannesburg
but it only he did it with aliens here
you have basically all the difficult
topics we have here in America right now
with border relations between the u.s.
and Mexico illegal aliens who should be
loud and they have right because should
people have jobs and it tackles it in a
way but it puts the haves and the
have-nots two halves are up in this
looks like halo you know speaking of
halo it looks like halo uh this paradise
called Elysium well the the poor people
are down on earth which is just awful
this is this gives me this is one of
Matt Damon's I think better performances
as he's done in a while he got back in
shape you got all cut and ripped I'd
like oh man let's do another Jason
Bourne movie but I don't know that's
gonna happen i loved how hispanic the
cast was i wasn't expected i think i
talk to you we're done seen like me
there's a lot of spanish in this movie
which I like because it's LA you know
those 100 years from now or something
like 2154 or something like that so I
liked it there are some things that were
rushed I mean Jodie Foster's character
wasn't developed as much but I love that
Blomkamp is taking these original sci-fi
ideas and branded the bigs I mean
they're not that many directors doing
good original sci-fi so saving JJ Abrams
is doing Star Wars and Star Trek but
Blomkamp is doing his own stories and I
really appreciate that yeah I like this
movie I have to be honest you was
actually one of my biggest
disappointment you're talking about
every yeah it was in the in my top like
three movies that I want to see this
year I saw it I enjoyed it I like it but
I didn't really come away loving it it's
not in my top five it's not even in my
top ten it's you know there's some cool
action sequences you know some good
performances I've had sharlto copley was
great as a villain I just didn't think
it gelled all that well for me like I
think some of the themes that he tried
to tackle which you know we're like the
immigration thing and the border thing
but then also health care as well yeah
you know for the haves and have-nots I
just I think he he tried to tackle too
much too many things at once and I don't
think it because i love district nine
yeah so i was expecting like something
like district nine you know but not not
the story i just mean in delivery and I
it fell short funny but I liked it
nonetheless alright so in the next movie
this is my pic in the in my top five
which is pacific rim hey i don't think i
had more fun at a movie this year then
pacific rim i think i saw three times in
the theaters like all imax all 3d just
like just being able to see the giant
robots running around fighting the giant
monsters look I understand the plots not
that great you know the characters
aren't that great like there's a lot
there's there's problems with them yeah
yeah I'm not I'm not denying this is not
pans labyrinth nooo yeah what to me it
was just like the epitome of like
popcorn blockbuster fun you know just
spectacle done in the right way but
unlike transformers which I feel like
that is not you know they use the visual
effects and stuff but like you can't
only follow the story it doesn't seem
that fun to me where this is just fun
this would make my top 10 and I want to
go off of what you were saying problem
with transformers is Michael Bay takes
himself serious yeah he thinks he's
making art and that's what bothers me is
again with a Toro he can do art he did
pans labyrinth and get his Oscar
nominations all that stuff at what he
did here is a look I want to bring out
your inner your inner 10 or 11 yeah he
said that before the movie and came out
this is supposed to just be you know big
giant robots fighting big monsters
that's all this is and he did it he
delivered on it it's fun it's it's
supposed to be cheesy supposed to like
get up in the morning watching your
Saturday morning cartoons that's what
that is brought on you know 200 million
yeah i love that i felt like i was a kid
playing with my like Voltron toys and my
Godzilla toys and having them fight and
stuff so yeah I just I didn't have any
more fun than I did then then in this
movie despite its flaws some news real
quick just recently wasn't down so well
it's rumored one of the actors guy
played one think the Austria
and the dad the data the the son he was
announced that the next Pacific Rim
could be a prequel there's a graphic
novel out right now that is a prequel
story so the next one that Guillermo del
Toro is working on could be a prequel if
it gets green let you know we'll see
yeah it's kind of that borderline phase
but yeah I hope that happens so next
movie is one of your pics the great
gasps this is interesting because a lot
of people saw this they're really
underwhelmed by I know you were kind
underwhelmed by you thought it was just
like for some reason I just gravitated
toward i love the visuals i think it's
cool it's just like a cool movie the 3d
look good i mean it's it's you know it's
what a baz lurman you know some will on
rules out of bright lights and shiny
fancy dresses but i just liked it i just
was just drawn to the it was such a
visual feast i know i don't think
there's much meat on it if I'm being
honest but it's such a visual feast I
was just drawn to that visual those
visual sensations how that cast was
great i love Leo in this role i'm sure i
haven't seen little you know wolf of
Wall Street we'll talk about that in a
little bit but I love Leo in this role I
thought it was great i really enjoyed
this movie yeah i mean i liked it it
thought it was okay you know like a
soundtrack it was enjoyable for me but
it wasn't like a movie that really got
ya was wasn't my top five wasn't in my
top ten but i thought yeah visually it
was cool and the one of the things that
I think was missing which we'll talk
about of why wolf of Wall Street is in
my top five is that I didn't get quite
that the sense of excess and indulgence
from that era that I thought like it was
gonna bring bits and pieces but yeah so
that brings us to the other leonardo
dicaprio movie wolf of Wall Street
Scorsese is one of my favorite directors
actually he is my favorite director that
doesn't mean I love all of them like I
like you going in look at you but to me
this this movie is is like Goodfellas
except for set up in Wall Street's good
films meets boiler yes boy if you've
seen boiler room so it combines that it
takes Goodfellas story structure and and
uses that the same type of like story
arc
editing in all that stuff in it is what
you know I thought Great Gatsby was
missing where it does show the excess
and indulgence you know this is said 80s
and early 90s of you know Canseco era
yeah I mean it's it talks about the
greed of American Capital right all
right and so on to our next one that we
both have in our top five list and it's
kind of like a controversial pick to
some people would be worse Star Trek
film by many Star Trek fans yeah star
trek into darkness I actually had a lot
of fun watching this movie I did I i
love that was one of my favorites yeah
you know you talk about that heli was
voted the worst it's hilarious because
that's from the die-hard Star Trek fans
who are like attached to the old Star
Trek look I can understand if you don't
like the movie I can understand if it's
you know if it's not your favorite or
you think other ones there's no way this
movie is worse than Star Trek
insurrection nope lowers the
insurrection not worsen final frontier
sky looking first but not worse I think
like one that much this is DJ I envied
you're like oh that's like come on like
this was fun JJ abrams made this movie
fun yeah it's weird cuz like Star Trek
that next generation is actually my
favorite Star Trek series and and people
who like how can you like this movie
like Star Trek The Next Generation Star
Trek The Next Generation yes it had like
deeper and heavier themes button that
doesn't I love first contact yeah
doesn't mean all their movies were that
great you know like when I think of
insurrection that isn't even good enough
to be a TV episode no it's that's I mean
sorry X best episodes trumped
introduction yeah it's ten times over I
mean first contact was so enjoyable and
some people loved it because I was one
of the more action-heavy you know it was
a star trek sometimes gets bogged down
in its own ideology and its own thought
process i'm at love star trek but
sometimes a good first content it's kind
of like let loose like it just had fun
this when we was having fun sure JJ's
doing more Star Wars and Star Trek with
it that's why he's doing Star Wars but
it was fun and some people didn't like
the flipping of the script yeah I
thought it was great I thought it was
great you know I thought it was a lot of
fun yes there are holes like we talked
about with Pacific Rim
are like things that are plot issues and
whatnot in it I just thought it was fun
yeah that's thing I left the movie I
think I said this know we did a review
it kind of like I left it when I left
Avengers I just had a lot of fun I was
like man that was a fun movie to watch
think I saw it three times in the
theater something like that yeah I think
I saw it twice yeah it was just fun yeah
now you know I had a friend who's not
just a casual moviegoer but he's he's a
film lover e works in the industry as
well and he loved it and he he has no
attachment to start trekking over he's
not a Star Trek fan he doesn't watch the
TV shows and it's not like he just he
likes only popcorn movies he loves like
art movies as well right and he thought
it was a lot of fun cuz like all these
Star Trek films are perfect no same with
legs like only Bennett hope JJ man
doesn't mess up Star Wars it's like Star
Wars you know last 15 years haven't been
the best for Star Wars fan so I mean we
only go up so I mean it's just a new
interpretation I think it's fun yeah I
mean ever there's so many different
interpretations of starch ikea voyager
deep space nine next generation the
original series of william shatner i
mean not all of them are exactly alike
and that's what I like about Star Trek
that all right so on to our next one
actually our last one gravity this is
the one that we both have in our top
five we saw like a year ago yeah we saw
two actually a while ago and then you
know we watched it recently they
actually didn't really change much in
terms of the edit or the cut it was all
the visual fat we're not that were final
out of finally finished now yeah cuz the
cut you you and me saw at the first time
was like a lot of like even just
previous stuff it was like an old video
game or something yeah like with without
any textures and stuff yeah I thought
this was a fantastic movie by Alfonso
Quran it's a simple story but with with
with heavier overarching themes to it
yeah you know rieber whole like you know
fuel-efficient acceptance of of death
and letting go button by doing that
being able to live your life rebirth of
her life that's basically kind of the
motif gray of this probably the best
space scenes I've ever seen in the movie
I mean not not to go realist I mean
because it's been so much stuff with me
it was so successful is like oh we
interviewed NASA specialist and they
added a lot of Nazca people too who
talked like are those a good movie not
realistic put a good movie again this it
does the movie does not begin with this
is based off a true story this is a
movie it's fiction but it's it's well
done it's beautiful it's again I
remember even we saw the
pre-visualization czar so good when
Sandra's like you know floating and
going with a fire well they have the
deferred the opening shot is like what
like a 20 minutes no cutscene you want
you to feel like you're in space space
yeah that's why there's very you know
not as many cuts in this movie because
they want it we did a review about this
if you want to check that out um well
it's gonna say about this movie yeah the
acting is good some of the dialogue I
think ya could have been cut out or
trimmed down a little bit but overall
it's a nice think it's only like
80-something minutes yeah I'm still
under an hour a half yeah yeah which I
think for this movie it's well yeah
there's not like anything like don't
like what I love about it is it's in
space there's a lot going on some
disaster stuff but it's not like the
fate of the world's at stake no
basically you know a couple astronauts
doing their mission and let's see if
they survive but I like this not like
apocalyptic you know it's really a small
movie but it's got a big scope but still
small the same time it's built I thought
was well done all right well then all
right guys so that's our top five movies
some of the stuff being David agreed on
some of them we disagreed on your list
yeah exactly let us know what you think
of our choices and what your favorite
movies of 2013 were you can post your
comments below on the website think
hero.com or on our youtube channel think
hero pro you also find us on twitter you
know Chad stuff about what you thought
your top five was runners-up top 10 top
20 whatever your list are you can pin
240 characters you can find us at think
hero i'm at griffin de we also have a
Facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think you're all fans make sure you like
that page you know help us out by
sharing and tweeting our videos put it
on Facebook and any other social network
channels
you